all right it looks like we're now live
for
another stoic sunday session and we're
still going through things having to do
with the four cardinal virtues we did
one session
earlier about the virtues in general to
kick everything off and we did another
session
last month on the virtue of wisdom we
were going to do this one
last month but i came down with kovid
and so that that became impossible
and so i'm still recovering but i think
i've got enough energy and uh you know
mental uh awareness to do a decent one
for this one and today we are going to
be looking at the second cardinal virtue
a very very important one for
understanding stoicism and that is the
virtue of
justice and it is one of the four
cardinal virtues that the stoics focus
on so let's you know review that very
quickly we've got wisdom or prudence we
have justice and then there's courage
and there's temperance and one of the
things that
people who've read the stoic text or
have been following a long know
is that each of these virtues contains a
number of what we can call sub-virtues
and you know they're they're not
distinguished or set out in exactly the
same classification from one's uh text
about stoicism or a stoic text to
another but uh justice is viewed as
absolutely central
and before we get into the nitty-gritty
of it
i'd like to
say
why
why
it's so important that we talk about the
virtue of justice when it comes to
understanding stoicism
and i think that a big reason besides
you know the value of understanding
stoicism as a philosophy
it's very important especially in our
own time when stoicism has become
popular and popularized
and there's many misunderstandings and
distortions of stoicism
out there
that we
focus on justice because by doing so we
overcome a tendency for some people to
distort stoicism into something that
it's not in other words to
create you could say a falsity a a lie
about stoicism itself which you know
that's that's kind of a problem i i
would say right um
so
what are the two things that that you
know
this study of justice is you could say
bringing to the table one of them
is overcoming the mistaken idea that
stoicism is about withdrawing from the
world into yourself into the inner
citadel to use
the the
phrase from marcus aurelius that
actually got turned into a book title by
pirado
stoicism is not about withdrawing from
the world or hardening yourself against
the world as if the world is your enemy
or
something like that
instead the stoics thought that you know
a good person
a wise just person is going to be
engaged with the world but it's it's how
they engage with the world so that's one
important thing to address another is
what we can call broicism uh you know
first we used to use this in a joking
way for all these manliness types out
there who are very unmanly actually by
classical standards but who are obsessed
with the ancient world and claim that
virtus comes from veer meaning man and
you know all these fanboys of the
spartans and stuff
what they espouse is not genuine
stoicism what they espouse is just being
a a tough guy who's actually sort of a
cream puff you know very gooey and weak
on the the inside and so there's focus
on tough toughness or over emphasis on
courage you know if we focus on justice
that helps to put these things in
perspective
cicero actually goes so far and actually
seneca says this too
that courage
without justice and of course wisdom is
not really courage it's actually a form
of cowardice people who are so
obsessed with appearing tough or really
scaredy cats so that's good to you know
start with
let's talk about terminology and texts
as we typically do
at the start of these things and by the
way i'm going to talk for maybe about
you know 20 30 minutes and then i'm
gonna address questions and comments so
you know if there's things that are
unclear along the way i'm happy to to
address them um so terminology and texts
with with justice there's a greek term
decay osunae
and a whole bunch of cognate terms uh
like today kion for the just or the
kaios for a just
you know person
or just a man
and in latin it's pretty straightforward
it's it's almost like the same thing as
we have in english is the english term
comes from it eustitia or eustis or usta
to describe the the person
so if we you know want to understand um
what these terms actually mean we have
to look at classic stoic text there's no
point in pretending to be interested in
stoicism if you aren't actually going
back to the classic texts because that's
you know those are the benchmarks those
are the baselines
so
um what do we what do we have
well as i mentioned before
we have the three big roman thinkers
seneca
and epictetus who should be at the core
supplemented by marcus aurelius right
but we also have musonius rufus who
you're going to notice me talking about
towards the end in in this and um
heracles the stoic and you know a few
other people here and there and then we
have these two really great
summaries of stoic doctrine that are not
by stoics but are giving us a lot of the
fill in the blanks kind of stuff and you
notice i'm going to talk about them
later on diogenes their tastes lives of
the philosophers and arias dynamises
epitome of stoic ethics so so far so
good who else do we need to take into
account well many of you have heard me
talk
at many times and in many videos about
cicero cicero is not himself a stoic
but he tells us more about stoicism than
many other people do
and
cicero is an absolutely invaluable
source
db is asking will this be uploaded this
is being uploaded right now that's what
a streaming video is on youtube um you
can watch this right now and then it
goes into the channel
so um
justice what is it justice really about
we're gonna get into some of the you
know uh you could say granular level
things but justice for the stoics is
fundamentally
about our human nature what is in
accordance with not just the you know
nature as the totality of being but are
distinctively human nature and what is
our distinctively human nature well you
know we're animals we're also rational
animals and for the stoics this is very
very important
part of what it means to be a rational
animal
is to be a
social animal to be an animal that lives
within societies
and this is absolutely
important we exist within families and
friendships and groups and societies and
even civilizations you'll notice that
cicero in one of the books that we're
going to talk about on duties
is going to talk about civilization
itself and so you know if we start
looking at some of the
texts uh and what the stoics thought
about things and diogenes liertes uh the
life of zeno chapter
99 he tells us that the stoics thought
all good is and he lists a whole bunch
of things expedient binding profitable
useful serviceable and it goes down to
the just or the right the decion and
what does this mean the good
is just
in so far as it is in harmony some
phonon which is another thing that the
stoics often well we'll talk about you
know being in harmony with nature in
this case though some phonon
nomo in accordance with the law
and what else produces community in the
greek it's
koinonias poeticon poeticon is to
produce right the sort of thing that
does produce or maintain in existence
and koinonia is literally a word that
means something like sharing something
that you have in common but it also
means community so justice
is something that or the just helps us
to produce and maintain community
seneca's letter 120 talks about the
different virtues and you know what
they're good for
and he says that
the desires had to be reigned in fear to
be suppressed proper actions to be
arranged
debts to be paid
and therefore we included self-restraint
bravery prudence and justice assigning
to each quality at special
function that is one function of justice
returning things that we ought to doing
our duties satisfying our obligations
cicero in his book on duties book one
tells us that you know out of the the
sort of primary impulses of human nature
we
eventually get to the point where we
realize
we need what justice provides us with
and he talks about there being four
sources
of the morally right the honest in latin
uh and justice is the one that is
concerned with the conservation of
organized society that's one thing
rendering each person they're due
another thing and faithful discharge of
obligations assumed so this is covering
quite a lot of ground
and he tells us that of these three
these four sources
besides wisdom the most extensive in its
application uh the most the broadest
latissima in latin
is that which from the principle by
which society and what we might call its
common bonds
are maintained so that's justice that
justice is oriented towards others and
towards our
common social
you know nature and experience and if we
look at stoic
figures
um they did not withdraw from their
society
they were involved in their society
sometimes they got exiled like masonis
rufus and seneca right and sometimes uh
well actually epictetus got kicked out
of rome uh by uh diocletian along with
all the other philosophers um so
sometimes that happens right and not
every single one of them held political
office but they when whenever there was
a a need for them to be involved
socially they did so zeno the founder of
stoicism was asked to come to macedon by
the king
and he said i'm sorry i can't do that
but he he sent one of his students to be
an advisor to the king
we know about cicero and cato taking
part in the roman civil war
on the side of pompeii who they didn't
think was a particularly good guy but he
was the lesser of of the two evils at
the time
there was the stoic plot against nero
which got seneca into trouble got
eventually got you know seneca targeted
by nero epictetus certainly did his part
in engaging political people he was a
teacher but you know people would come
to him for advice
including one guy that we're going to
talk about a little bit later and then
of course there's marcus aurelius
who is emperor and trying to
live you know a stoic life and you know
writing to himself and we know about
about that because of his book the
meditations or to himself
so
justice is clearly something important
for the stoics to think about but also
you know within the the models that we
have
um
what do we learn about
uh justice by looking at these texts so
you heard me mention diogenes laertes
already
um
diogenes tells us that the cologne the
beautiful the good
has four types and one of those is
concerned with what is just in greek the
toddy kaion
and you know he tells us in in
section 128 that if a person has virtue
they can figure out and do what ought to
be done and
what ought to be done
includes these different things what
should be chosen right what should be
endured what should be
stayed and what should be distributed
and the distributed thing that has to do
with justice how do we
how do we dole things out how do we
uh decide who's going to be in charge
that's distributing power how do we
allocate income or wealth or you know
all these sorts how do we even allocate
our attention or our affection to people
and so
we can look at how these things
break down
and so in diogenes lierte he doesn't get
very deep into this he talks about
justice including two main
parts to it equality isotase in greek
and fair-mindedness
right
and it doesn't really tell us what these
these terms mean but when we go to aries
didymus
then we get a fuller breakdown and it's
it doesn't you know correspond to
diogenes laertes i think one of the
things i do want to say too
at this point and i may have to
reiterate this later
is that when we get these different
breakdowns of what justice includes we
should look at them not as opposed to
each other but as complementing each
other as adding in parts that need to be
brought up or emphasized so what does
arius didymus say that justice includes
he talks about four different
sub-virtues
piety eusebia
kindness chrystotes
good fellowship
eukononesia
and fair dealing
is tsunaloxia
and each of these is a greek term and
then arius didymus goes on to explain
what what each of these is and like a
stoic he says that each of these is a
kind of knowledge right but it's a kind
of practical knowledge about how to do
something how to make decisions
and so piety which we wouldn't typically
associate with justice but it was pretty
common to connect it with justice in the
ancient world you'll notice that um
plato uh does that in in his works at
times
um piety is knowledge of the service the
therapea
of the gods and so you know if you don't
believe in gods or the divine you can
probably put that aside that's not a big
deal
you could think in terms of whatever it
is that you consider to be the the
highest i mean if you consider virtue to
be the highest thing then maybe
piety is in relation to virtue right
um now the other three
that's a little bit um
you know different so kindness christ
knowledge which is disposed he says to
do good you poyiti and you might say
what the hell does it have to do with
justice with like you know fair
distribution of things or as you know
dbd is is bringing up punishment we'll
talk about punishment in a bit um what
is kindness or you know being disposed
to do good
uh you poise literally means creating uh
things being good
and we'll get to that that that turns
out to be a major part of the way stoics
understand justice
then we have good fellowship
you coino nacia and you notice that that
term coinone is coming up again right
what we have in common and the ew is
good
so
interestingly arius didymus calls this
knowledge of equality
in partnership
esotes and koinonia so you notice
that this isotase is coming up again a
fairness an equality or
something like
like that right
and then we have what what gets
translated as fair dealing
knowledge of how to deal with one's
neighbors without incurring blame that
sounds pretty specific right so why
would you be uh incurring blame well
because you're dealing with them in the
wrong ways you're not you're not being
fair you're you know you're cheating
them
you're
prioritizing
your own good over their good or you
know something along those lines right
any of those sorts of things so now
we've got quite a few ideas sort of
constellated in terms of what justice is
supposed to include let's make it a
little bit more complicated but we're
going to start bringing things into
a
tighter connection
cicero
on duties which by the way
is
in large part coming from cicero
reworking
the middle stoic peneteuses
on duties right so it is a stoic text
even though it's not by a explicitly
stoic author
cicero tells us
that there's two main divisions
of this this virtue which has to do or
the source of goodness which has to do
with our our common nature and society
one he says is justice eustitia and he
says something really interesting here
it is the crowning glory
of the virtues
and it is on the basis of justice that
men he uses the word beauty there but we
could say human beings
are called good so this is this is
pretty important stuff right
um
justice in a certain way isn't just a
virtue among the virtues it's the
crowning glory of the virtues
and you might say you know if you know
you're cicero and you or you at least
you know your quotes right you might say
wait a second i thought gratitude was
the mother of the virtues of the parent
of the virtues for cicero yes and
gratitude will actually be
part of justice
so
yes that's quite true and so that's one
side right and then
he says closely akin to it
is um what you know it's translated as
charity in the lobe addition but a
better closer translation is just
beneficence
or doing good to other people
beneficentia which he tells us is also
called by two other names
kindness
or generosity liberalitas so notice this
is a great you know great response to
people who are like i don't understand
why the stoics you know they've only got
these four virtues and they you know
justice that's nice but what about
kindness well that's part of justice for
the stoics that is a central part it's
half of justice right and so um what
what's what's on both sides so so cicero
tells us that justice proper
includes a number of different things
and and i don't think that we should try
to reduce these to
one single principle we should honor the
fact that justice includes a lot of
stuff so one key thing
is to keep people from harming each
other unless provoked by
wrong so to go to the you know somebody
uh and asked about um punishment
you can punish uh that's often part of
justice
sometimes punishment is taking something
away from somebody
who like defrauded somebody and giving
it back to the person who got it
sometimes it's just you know
imprisoning somebody or you know in
ancient times corporal punishment or
exile or all these other sorts of things
as well
but keeping people from harming other
people that is a primary part of justice
and cicero says it's not enough uh just
to not harm people yourself if you can
keep other people from harming people
you actually have a duty to to do that
and then he says a second important part
of justice is leading people to use
common possessions for common interest
this is a very nice way of talking about
how if you actually have
say power or authority or decision
making capacity
you have a duty to work not just for
your own benefit or say the benefit of
your shareholders like
if you're you know a ceo of a company
but for the common good if what you're
doing is using social goods
like roads or the internet or stuff like
that
you're not supposed to simply
appropriate it to your private or
corporate
use
private property is is you know uh an
important part of stoic
conceptions of justice but the common
good is also
really central there as well
then
he talks about contributing to this
common good by the interchange of acts
of duties in media of
uh
is how he
says it in the latin
giving and receiving right so economic
exchange is part of that but also the
things that are not strictly economic
but are matters of what we call
benefits and gratitude
our skills our ti boosts our industry or
our deeds oprah and
talents
facultatibus and these cement society
between human beings so that's part of
justice and then another key part is
what he calls good faith
fides trust right
loyalty you could say and he glosses
that as truth and fidelity and there he
uses the word
constantia like remaining constant again
you could translate it as loyalty to the
promises and agreements that we make so
now we've got like keeping people from
being harmed um you know
working towards some sort of common good
making sure the common good doesn't get
just appropriated by private individuals
or or you know people who have power
and we have good faith and
cicero will go so far
as to say
that we owe justice even to enemies
now not necessarily all enemies if
somebody if some group shows themselves
as being like the total enemy of
civilization you know like if you're
dealing with the mongols or uh if you're
dealing with uh the nazis cicero would
say well they're they're beyond the pale
but
most enemies are not that and this would
also extend to criminals too right
he also tells us that we need to extend
justice to those who are most
disadvantaged and lowest and who is that
in his society slaves and he tells us
that you know it's a good rule that
slaves must be treated as employees uh
in latin uh mercanaris which is the word
we get mercenary from wage earners right
they do have to work but you have to pay
them the right amount and you can't
arbitrarily exercise power over them
because that would be
unjust right so that's just as proper on
cicero's side what about the other half
what about beneficence we should
do good to other people and you could
even say maybe to to other kinds of
beings as well
cicero provides us with some rules for
this though he doesn't say well i'll
just be a nice guy all the time
he says acts of kindness should not
prove an injury or uh to the person
who's being benefited or to others so
giving an alcoholic you know a whole
case of beer not really doing a good
thing for them right or uh stealing from
one person or in order to benefit others
no no that's that's not um
the right way to benefit people he also
says that we shouldn't benefit people
beyond our means we should take our own
needs into account
you know we should be honest about that
we probably do have more that we can
give to other people than we typically
think we do and then he says and this is
a complex matter that we're not going to
go like deep into here
it needs to be proportioned to the
worthiness of the recipient so that
could include like their character
and um
shanagarh says can you tell us what
books quotes come from i have been
telling you what books quotes are coming
from cicero on duties right you got to
listen at the start when i when i bring
up somebody aries didymus epitome of
stoic ethics um diogenes lyrites lives
of the philosophers those are the ones
we've talked about so far
so
beneficence has to be proportioned to
the worthiness of the recipient that
includes our relationship to them so
cicero thinks that it's okay to you know
favor our family sometimes not to favor
them in such a way that we violate
justice
in other respects but you know it is
okay for us to benefit those closest to
us um we might also think about those
who have benefited us in the past so we
we owe something like a debt of
gratitude to
so that's that's quite important
who else should we we think about is
we're trying to expand this conception
of
justice well epictetus discourses are
full of this right if you read your way
through the four books that we possess
of epictetus's discourses
you know looks like there were eight in
ancient times but we only have four
you notice that he talks about roles and
he talks about duties over and over and
over again
those have to do even if he's not using
the word
those have to do with the virtue of
justice
and i'll give you one prime example
there's a guy who comes to him and this
is pretty typical for epictetus right he
he had a lot of people soliciting advice
from him including political authorities
so i think it's a pro career otter uh
who's sort of a you know over a
territory and he's all mad because he
went to the theater uh where there was
like a
a contest going on between comedic
actors and he liked one actor and the
crowd liked the other
and so then
he started shouting at the crowd and the
crowd started shouting at him and
eventually he leaves the theater and
he's like can you believe those jerks
and epictetus is like
buddy
you acted like a jerk too
and
what's wrong with you don't you realize
that by virtue of having this higher
position
you're supposed to be setting an example
of fairness
and good behavior i mean you you know
those rum dums who are going to the
theater they're going to act like that
but you're supposed to be
better so it's not fair for you to
criticize them for yelling at you
you need to be doing something
better than they are providing them with
an example this is a prime example
of how justice is being understood in
epictetus's discourses
a couple other things coming from
sonia's rufus
and cicero so in masonis rufus is
lecture three which is about you know
should women be taught philosophy
he he says yes because they need the
virtues just as much as a man does
and so he says and we should we should
think about this as as we're hearing it
we shouldn't think about it in a
gendered way we should think about this
as applying to all of us
he says as for justice would not the
woman who studies philosophy be just
would she not be a blameless life
partner would she not be a sympathetic
help mate would she not be an untiring
defender of husband and children and
would she not be entirely free of greed
and arrogance now if we pause on that we
can say yeah everybody should be free of
greed and arrogance and okay maybe you
don't have a life partner that's fine
then that doesn't apply to you but you
could also be you know a good person to
your colleagues
at work or to
uh the people who you live with or pick
whoever else you're involved with and
then he goes on and says who better than
the woman trained in philosophy
would be disposed to look upon doing a
wrong as worse than suffering one and to
regard being worsted is better than
gaining an unjust advantage moreover who
better than she would love her children
more than life itself what woman would
be more just than such a one saying we
these are the sort of things that
justice looks like and involves
cicero in on duties um book one tells us
nature by the power of reason associates
human beings and the common bonds of
speech and life she implants now notice
these these things that he he talks
about
in a human being a tender love for
offspring okay so that's something that
we ought to have
she also
prompts people to meet in companies to
form public assemblies and to take part
in them
she further dictates as a consequence of
this the effort on the human being's
part to provide a store of things that
minister to his comforts and wants and
not for himself alone but for his spouse
and children and others he holds dear
and for whom he ought to provide this is
part of justice
taking care of yourself
by being you know productive and
earning and also setting aside things
for those who are dependent upon
you who you want to take care of
who you want to benefit in your turn
seneca in letter 81 tells us that
the good person is going to judge what
will be the fairest response in
comparing benefits and injuries but he
will incline towards benefits he will
lean in that direction
he will be easy to bargain with generous
and acknowledging an obligation
reluctant to make an injury cancel out a
benefit all his inclination all his
wishes will tend towards gratitude and
thanks so this is also part of what it
means to be a good person in the mode of
justice
and i do want to close and i'll start
addressing these these questions and
comments with another letter by seneca
letter 95
he's you know
he's saying i don't have to provide you
with rules about every single thing he's
writing to his friend lucilius and he
says why should i mention every service
one should perform every kind of harm
one should avoid doing instead i can
pass on the following general rule
concerning human duties
the universe that you see containing the
human and the divine is a unity we are
the limbs of a mighty body
nature brought us to birth as
kin
since it generated all of us from the
same materials and for the same purposes
endowing us
with affection for one another and
making us companionable
nature established fairness and justice
led our hands
our hands be available to help whenever
necessary i think this is a great
example of you know once again seneca
who wrote an entire book on benefits
that we're going to talk about later on
down the line
viewing justice as requiring us to go
beyond just what the law says or just
what fairness dictates and think about
how we would help
other other people and perhaps going
beyond that other beings within this
universe that we share together so
that's hopefully giving you a fuller
conception of what the stoics
mean
uh
encompass you know extend justice
and let me start addressing some of
these uh
questions and comments so
blank name has a good question here
do you think socioeconomic factors might
prevent someone from
practicing stoicism like if you're
always stressed it must be harder to be
a stoic and so the the simple answer is
the stoics say no
and you know the soix
lived in a world in which there is
incredible socioeconomic unfairness
and one of the things you know that
that's different about the stoic school
compared to say the aristotelians
is the idea that you can practice virtue
and develop it no matter what
circumstances you're in
it might not always be
easy right there could be greater
difficulty and there can be stress
but you can do an awful lot on your end
progressively not just by snapping your
fingers and becoming a stoic right but
like you know working at it you can uh
get yourself to the point where things
that bothered you in the past and kept
you from like having a just response to
somebody um
won't do that so much you know
i mean just recently
um i i had covid and you know that's
pretty stressful to like at the end of
the semester uh not be able to uh uh you
know get out of bed and get things done
and you know um
my cat also died you know my 19 year old
sassy who i was very very close with
you know bonded to
more than any other animal and of course
i feel grief but it's not it's not um
disabling me as it might have
20 years ago some of that is due to
practicing stoicism you know among other
life philosophies as well and you know
you can say the same thing so you work a
crappy job and your manager's a dick and
all these sorts of things right
um
you notice that some people it's not
like you you have to say well that's
okay everything's fine right like the
meme with the dog sitting in the thing
you can call something at injustice you
can say that person's a jerk they're
terrible i'm being underpaid that
doesn't have to make it impossible for
you to
to flourish you know
so
um
yeah socioeconomic factors don't prevent
stoicism they do generate obstacles and
difficulties right
um
another one what do i think of william
irvine
i find he's too narrow-minded sometimes
he seems to apply stoicism to everything
being narrow-minded
and applying stoicism to everything
those would be two different things i
mean
why wouldn't you apply stoicism to
everything if you're a stoic right
um that's not being narrow-minded that's
actually being very broad-minded
um
i think he can be
kind of narrow-minded and
um you know one of the things that that
he got into as a controversy
was
he's you know he's on the side of the
the people who are you know who tend to
view
um
the younger generation as being too
touchy right he gave a talk at stoicon
about
microaggressions and how we should just
sort of shrug those off and then you
know
eric scott rightly wrote a piece in
response saying
you know
i think you're underplaying this there
are some serious justice issues
and
just telling other people suck it up and
be stoic is not really
a cool response
um especially when you know you're in a
much better position than they are
professor
and you know i think that might be a
kind of
narrow-mindedness right
so
all right
any similarity between hegel's
philosophy from his whole system and
stoicism no more than to anything else i
mean hegel is much more closely
connected i would say to aristotelianism
than he has stoicism hegel also
gets the stoics mostly wrong he
discusses them at a couple points and he
gets them mostly wrong in the same way
that other people from his time were
getting them mostly wrong
viewing stoicism and the other
hellenistic philosophies is basically
a response to the decline of the greek
city-state and the kind of freedom that
went with it and trying to withdraw
within yourself um
so there's there's no intrinsic
connection between stoicism and
hegel
um
jeremy asks is it not making obligations
something i heard and said before yeah
obligations are a central part of
justice right if you
uh sign a contract with somebody it's
just for you to honor the contract
although you know cicero himself in on
duties will say
not every agreement like if it's a
coerced agreement that's not an
agreement you know you were coerced into
it so you don't actually have to
honor it
um
all right let's see
uh
jeremy says sometimes bad speech to text
i'm driving wasn't there something said
about not acquiring obligations could
you expound on that
no no nothing was said about not
acquiring obligations it's it's more
about fulfilling your obligations that
you have agreed to or undertaken right
so
um
stan to find a contradiction between the
stoics pleased to meet you seneca thinks
that one shall be punished not for
revenge due to other bad feelings but to
correct that person epictetus on the
other hand says the opposite epictetus
on the other hand does not say the
opposite at all
you've misread epictetus somewhere and
what you're thinking about with seneca
is from on anger for the most part where
uh seneca says you shouldn't be
correcting somebody in anger cicero by
the way says the same thing
but that the judge might sometimes
pretend to be angry so as to try to get
the
uh the
person who's doing bad actions to take
it seriously but there isn't a
contradiction between seneca and
epictetus on this part as a matter of
fact epictetus says the opposite of what
you say is the opposite namely that why
why would you you know think that
getting angry at somebody and trying to
you know punish them in return
is rational it's actually irrational and
unwise to do so because it's actually
screwing you up in the process you're
like well that because that person
screwed themself up and then thereby
because of their screwed up but
screwed-upedness uh attacked me i'm
gonna make myself screwed up just like
they are so i can retaliate epictetus
says that's that's nuts that's
counterproductive so there there there
isn't any uh contradiction there between
these two great stoic authors
what other questions or comments do
people
have about the
virtue of justice or stoicism more
broadly
i can hang out for a little bit you can
tell my my lungs are still not in in
great
shape at this point in time but all
right so
uh stan says gregory can you give
reference pre please refer encoring i
didn't refer to the uncreated at all and
i've given references at each point in
this talk so
um fusion i'm going to watch the
previous two sessions first yeah suit
yourself do whatever you want you know
they're they're all there in the channel
uh shane garm which of the stoic authors
speak and how we should treat say
animals how might they view our modern
day food mass production chain every one
of the stoics
who
we could talk about
in ancient times would look at modern
factory farming and after they'd
finished puking
they would be
very
you know concerned about about the
just sheer production of misery for the
need to have convenience on the part of
human beings
now who are them talk about animals i
mean seneca to some degree
cicero to some degree you do have to
keep in mind that the ancient stoics
viewed things in a sort of hierarchical
fashion right and this is not just the
stoics this is the platonous this is the
aristotelians this is ancient philosophy
in general
you have you have non-living being bare
being
then you have living being then you have
sentient being and then you have
rational being and the lower forms of
being exist for the higher forms of
being
so animals strictly speaking exist for
us does that mean that we can do
whatever the hell we want to
no
you know that would that would be wrong
and it would be wrong um in part to
those other beings right um
to be the opposite of beneficent to them
to be imposing pain on them just so you
can have you know bigger chicken breasts
or you know the bacon that you want to
or uh pick whatever else you want um
stoics would be for ethical farming i
mean we when we order meat
um you know costs us more but the cow
only has one bad day right as opposed to
a whole life of of misery being treated
like a tool so
all right um
juice box what does stoicism say about
capital punishment
you can do capital punishment got to
make sure it's just
that you know what does stoicism say
about every one of the little issues
that we might bring up it's got to be in
accordance with you know justice
this is pretty straightforward
um
christopher do you have any tips on how
to actually get oneself to start acting
on these lessons
well the first thing is to start acting
on the lessons right and then to stick
to it and to keep studying it and to you
know maybe get together with other
people so you have accountability and to
keep studying it and keep studying it
and keep studying it i mean it's a
dialectic of back and forth there is no
magic bullet there is no
uh one thing you know uh or method
that's gonna get all these things
lined up for you stoicism is a
constellation of a whole bunch of
concepts and practices
and you just like with any other thing
like learning to play guitar or
um you know mastering a language you
learn bits of it at a time and you keep
on working at it and
you know you um
a lot of it is is like sticking to it
uh and and working through it even when
you don't want to and then at a certain
point something changes and you're like
holy crap
um this stuff is actually working for me
so yeah
uh jeremy what hap what if someone took
a cup of coffee don't they deserve
righteous anger i mean if you're getting
righteously angry at somebody i mean
stomachs don't think there's righteous
anger anyway if you get pissed off at
somebody over a cup of coffee
which basically costs sense to make
you get problems you know
cups of coffee are pretty small in the
order of things i mean it's not like
somebody stole your truck or somebody
stole your tools that are your
livelihood or somebody you know pushed
you down an elevator shaft if somebody's
just taken a cup of coffee i think all
these stoics would be like why are you
getting upset about that you know those
sort of things happen think about
epictetus and caridian where he says
is a little oil spilt
that's the price of tranquility does
your slave drink a little bit of your
wine that's the price of tranquility so
a cup of coffee is pretty small small
stuff right
um
larabib can you give some great stoic
book suggestions they're right there in
the video description right
and we've talked about a number of them
here classic stoic texts
epictetus discourses seneca's letters
seneca's other treaty sees marcus
aurelius's meditations
this is all stuff that's i mean i've
actually got a medium article of book
suggestions you just type in gregory
sadler stoic reading suggestions and
you'll get like a whole sequential list
of what you might want to go through
right
carl bed epictetus suggests at the end
of every night look back on all the
times in the day you failed to control
what you could and think intentionally
about how you should have acted
differently actually he doesn't suggest
that that's uh that's uh it's more
seneca who talks about the end of the
day practice like that epictetus talks
about you know
keeping track of what's going on for
instance how many times you've lost your
temper but i think you're probably
getting that from a gloss on epictetus
rather than epictetus himself
um
changgarm we have a fellowship we're
trying to start on discord and become
doing video meetings anyone here is
welcome to join
uh yeah okay
i don't do discord myself much because
uh i already got enough other things
going on
fabian what was the stoic view on family
and children did they have like
babysitters or teachers or do they care
spend a significant time with them yes
both it depends totally on your
circumstances do you can you afford a
babysitter then maybe you have a
babysitter do you have the the luxury of
spending lots of time with your children
then you spend lots of time with your
children there isn't a stoic take on
whether they're to have your children in
you know daycare or or preschool or
babysitting or not it all depends on on
the circumstances this is where like the
virtue of prudence would come in right
you think about well what makes the most
sense what's going to be best for my my
kids right
um
all right
but any any other questions there's a
lot of back and forth chat going on but
i'm not gonna get into that any other
questions comments
clarifications
we got about 12 minutes before we hit
the top of the hour
if we don't have many all i'll end the
session
short because i can certainly use the
downtime but if anybody does have
questions or comments i'm happy to to do
it
okay so blank name what does stoic say
about motivation what if you are someone
who doesn't have motivation you aren't
somebody who doesn't have motivation
you're somebody who chooses not to have
motivation
uh or you know feels lethargic and then
doesn't exercise the you know the virtue
of courage which includes things like
endurance and taking on you know
perseverance and stuff like that
um
i mean that's one of the things about
stoicism no no stoic says that you can
snap your fingers and suddenly be a
different person
every stoic thinks that you have some
measure of control
over your own mind and emotions and what
you think about and what you choose to
do and you can slowly build yourself
towards having more as you're calling it
motivation
so that that's basically what the stoics
had to say about that
man
any other
questions comments
oh okay so death tones you may have
covered this in the past
what got you into philosophy or stoicism
specifically was it a zeno scenario
being shipwrecked seeing your your
wealth flowing out into the athens
harbor or just through study so there's
there's two answers
one for uh philosophy one for stoicism
i
got exposed to philosophy
um fairly young
and i was doing things that would be
called philosophy without knowing that
it was philosophy
as a kid you know i liked i liked
arguing i liked trying to understand the
nature of things i liked figuring things
out
comparing things against each other you
know i liked getting into discussions
about about ethical matters
and then i had two philosophy classes in
high school one of which was an actual
philosophy class and it was terrible
and then another one was actually a
sacraments class taught by this guy mr
lorenzo
and he taught us plato and aristotle and
augustine
and
i thought that was awesome and he also
conducted the class in a philosophical
manner and then i went in the army and i
you know i read a little bit of stuff
about philosophy there and then i got
out and i was working in restaurants and
you know and then i i went to college
and then i was you know i declared a
philosophy major
uh in part because
um
you know i i was told by my mom's old
boyfriend declare a major when you get
in and i was like philosophy sounds cool
i'll do that and i just kept taking
classes and i enjoyed it and had an
aptitude for it and
here i am uh uh 32 years later um
it's become you know a major part of my
life now stoicism i studied some stoic
stuff you know like i read the end
caridian and the meditations as a
college student
but i wasn't really that attracted to it
until two important things
changed that
one was reading epictetus discourses
and i found it in a used bookstore and
i'm reading it and i was like holy crap
this is about the stuff i'm really
interested in uh you know like freedom
of the will and how do you change habits
and how do you know what's the
connection between
uh your the way you think about things
and the way you you choose things so
that was that was kind of a turn on for
me and epictetus remains my favorite
stoic
and then um from about you know the 19
late 1990s i began
doing a lot of intensive study of
ancient philosophy oriented towards
understanding theories of anger
because i you know i was an angry person
and struggled a lot with anger and you
know so part of that was like studying
aristotle someone was studying plutarch
but the stoics were also
really important for that and that that
also got me to take the stoics seriously
so
all right um juice box and a perspective
of stoicism can there be such a thing as
too much suffering of course suffering
of different sorts it it may be an you
know an indifferent in many cases but
their dispreferred indifference right
poverty is not a good thing
as a matter of fact it's better to have
resources than to be impoverished it's
better to be healthy than to be sick
it's just not going to make you virtuous
having a ton of money or not having any
money
but yeah i mean the stoics would say
there's
why would you want people to suffer or
animals to suffer for that reason going
back to the factory farming thing you
know it's it's imprudent it's unjust to
um increase the amount of suffering you
know
all right uh
shannon shanagarh says wanted to thank
you for doing these oh you're very
welcome uh
jeremy says looking forward to this
um a lot of people are saying
uh
uh
thanks you're all welcome bob tarmac is
too much stoicism toxic to living fully
no uh too much [ __ ] like not actual
stoicism would be right i mentioned
broissism at the very beginning this is
like the i'm a tough guy you know sort
of sort of thing that's not real
stoicism it is toxic
it's a living fully but
no um
as a matter of fact
most people have so little stoicism that
they don't need to worry about whether
their stoicism rightly understood is
keeping them from living fully until
they've actually got to the point where
they're they're practicing it then that
can be an issue right
julian does seneca's book on benefits
teach uh on the virtue of justice a lot
yes and no it doesn't mention justice a
lot it
it does teach implicitly a lot about a
part of of justice
and it's well worth reading on benefits
is a great book
i would definitely check it out
um
jaunty good what did the stoic say about
vegetarianism some of the stoics were
for it
some of them don't don't really
care it's not a
it's not a stoic thing to be a
vegetarian as a matter of fact
if you're like a
vegetarian or a vegan who's like getting
in everybody's faces and being a jerk
you're definitely not a stoic right
because the stoic would would like
practice it and mostly keep their mouth
shut and maybe engage in some light
advocacy you know
um
blank name what do the stoics say about
identity do we create it it depends on
what you mean by identity you know
um
to some degree we're responsible for who
we are and the kind of people that we
are you know it's kind of i mean this is
this is
every virtue ethic says that we have
some measure of
control over
how our habits are formed and what we
prioritize so if that's what you think
of as
identity then i guess sure
if identity you you're thinking of
something like
um whether i have control over being an
american or being a 51 year old
person at this point in time or whether
i'm uh
you know an english speaker probably not
so much right i mean i could like lose
my capacity to speak english right
um but
those are kind of eccentric things
uh
raw what's stoicism take on love this is
be this would be a great place for you
to google gregory sadler stoicism love
and i've written an entire article about
it
uh years back i've also done you know i
at stoicon 2018 i did an entire
workshop on the stoics on and erotic or
romantic relationships so you know what
they have to say about love is kind of
complex
um
dbd
does the stoic say anything about
reality yeah there's reality i mean what
do you want them to say about reality
that's that's one of those like super
stratospheric questions that i don't
know what you're you're actually looking
for uh the stoics to say about that some
things are real yeah
stoics are for being in touch with
reality
what else any any other questions we've
got about another three minutes left
oh man
christa christofias can a deterministic
worldview be merged with a stoic idea of
having control of one's judgments and
emotions totally depends on what you
mean by a deterministic worldview
because it doesn't mean the same thing
to every single person the books you
wouldn't want to read about that would
be
citizenrosan fate and of course you want
to read epictetus on on that sort of
thing and
seneca will talk about causes and stuff
like that at times as well
levi i wanted to say thank you for your
videos my philosophy professor linked us
to your lecture videos every week they
really helped me understand aristotle's
writings and ideas that's good yeah um
i'm i'm glad here's a good question from
uh sophia and how to handle a breakup
like a true stoic
well first off stay broke up most likely
right
if you're the one who like was the
dumper and you had good reasons for
dumping them
it's natural to be like oh i kind of
missed them let's give it another try if
you had good prudent reasons for for
breaking up
then um
stay broken up
you know if you were the dumpy
and you know you're you're pining after
that person
you could say ah
maybe
maybe i should redirect myself
towards either another relationship or
towards um
you know
uh
other things you know maybe maybe it's
not time to be in a relationship right
now maybe it's time to work on my
um
habits and
um work on you know my
health and things like that right
um
all right julian is justice considered
to be the crowning virtue by most stoics
or is it just limited to cicero's
own opinion
um
well it's it's the crown uh it's like
the crown of the virtues is how cicero
says it and it's uh
yeah very important you know
um
epictetus talks less about virtue and he
talks less about the particular virtues
than say seneca does seneca thinks it's
pretty damn important wisdom is is you
know
as we talked about last time super
important for the stoics as well
um
not sure what the shannon graham
do not read dr sailor for people enchant
uh
thing is but
something probably self-referential
there all right well we're at the top of
the hour um good questions and comments
hopefully justice is a little bit you
know clearer to you what the stoics are
into
um and uh
you know
why why it's so centrally important to
the stoics so
we'll we'll do another one of these in
two weeks talking about courage and
other pretty misunderstood virtue but i
do want to tell you about something it's
in the video description i'm offering a
free
class session
next sunday on light hall which is a new
platform that's in beta that i'm trying
out
and it's on
stoic practices in epictetuses and
caridian
you can sign up for it and for and and
go to it for free
um if light hall
works well i'll probably be doing some
other class sessions using that i may
actually shift away from using youtube
live and to lighthall because it's got a
lot of really cool features that are not
available
in
uh youtube live
so
again video
description has has that link if you if
you're interested in that otherwise i'll
probably see all of you next not next
sunday but the sunday after that where
we'll do the next stoic sundays thing
and
have a great rest of the day or whatever
whatever's left of it whatever time zone
you're in